Hulu's new Hellraiser tells a gruesome
Tale one that ends in Carnage Gore and
explorations of the true nature of
desire it has such sights to show you
the best stories in the Hellraiser
Universe are always exploring how far a
particular person will go to get what
they want in the case of the 2022 film
that question extends to two different
people Riley and Mr void they both come
to the legendary puzzle box through
entirely different circumstances
Desiring entirely different things and
reaching entirely different conclusions
but for most of the film it's Riley's
Journey that takes Center Stage Riley
finds the Box amid a struggle with
addiction and directionless living
hoping that the potential riches the
object might bring will turn her life
around in some way or another what she
finds instead is pain and Untold horror
as she loses her brother and finds
herself at the center of a vast
terrifying secret from which she may
never be able to escape
are boundless so what the
yes you
by the end of the film with the secrets
of the box and the cenobites it
unleashes laid bare she has learned that
this journey offers no easy answers and
no magical Solutions all she can do the
Box teaches her is surrender to its
power or carve a path forward by herself
she chooses the latter to the cenobites
dismay and in the process grows as a
person realizing that she must face her
pain rather than attempt to circumvent
or transform it it's a difficult choice
but it's the one that seemingly leaves
Riley free to live life on her terms as
Riley discovers when she stumbles upon
voit's research the puzzle box called
the lament configuration in the previous
centuries in the franchise has a long
strange history much like the box from
the original Hellraiser it has a
mythology built up behind it based on
Decades of people seeking its wonders
but unlike that box it has extra layers
to its various configurations there are
six in total yielding different gifts
based on the solution by delivering
blood and souls to this version of The
Box the user can reach new levels of
experience and even choose their fate
when reaching the cenobites god
Leviathan this adds a certain depth to
the story of the box which is
particularly clear when Riley discovers
that Voigt survived his encounter with
the artifact though he was transformed
into a being in constant pain by the
cenobites this suggests that more than
one person has in some form lived to
tell the tale of the box and their
adventures with it and if the right
person picks up that trail they just
might find a trove of new information
Riley leaves the Box behind suggesting
she's not the person to keep
investigating its Secrets but that
doesn't mean the blocks will be
abandoned forever if we've learned
anything from this franchise so far
someone else is bound to grow curious
activate the box and search for new
truths about its history what they find
and how it changes them seems like
perfect fodder for a sequel
because Voigt survived his encounter
with Leviathan at the end of his first
journey with the puzzle box he can
impart certain information about what
the cenobites are and what they want as
he explains to Riley every choice the
beings present to the user of the box is
a trick a doorway to some Untold pain
that varies based on the user but
nevertheless always comes back to
suffering
I saw the pleasure
with all they have to give
his pain
in his quest to give back his gift the
liminal configuration which pushes his
nerve endings to maximum pain at every
opportunity Voigt puts more and more
people In Harm's Way only to be told at
the End by the hell priest that there is
no retreat once the threshold has been
crossed all he can do is make an
exchange at the hell priest's behest he
chooses the Leviathan configuration
granting him the power that his true
nature was always seeking what he
doesn't know and what the last scene
reveals is that this means he will
become a cenobite in service to the
constant pursuit of Anguish the film
leaves us without a clear picture of
voit's cenobite future but it seems
quite possible that a sequel would see
him standing side by side with the hell
priest working the dark magic of the
cenobites on others what this means for
his human form his memories and other
aspects of the man he was remains to be
seen
as with the original Hellraiser we're
introduced to the lead cenobite
popularly known as Pinhead
in the new movie they're known in this
film as the hell priest the monster
exists to fulfill their role as a
servant of the puzzle box we never learn
much about the hell priest's backstory
most of what we know about the character
is from their role in the story not how
Hell priest came to be or why but that
doesn't mean the hell priest is without
personality at least twice in the film
we see the creature react with surprise
amusement or both as their order is
challenged by both Voigt and Riley in
different ways this suggests that the
hell priest like their predecessor is
not immune to Bargains compromises or
simply intriguing new configurations of
the order they've established with any
luck future films could grant us some
more personal detailed look at who and
what the hell priest is much as
Hellbound Hellraiser 2 does and what led
them to choose the Leviathan
configuration and ultimately become a
cenobite in the process we might learn
what continues to drive this character
and what if anything they hope to gain
from continuing to fulfill the role for
all eternity
as Hellraiser goes on we get more and
more insights into Voigt and his
years-long search for the furthest
reaches of human experience which
included turning his Mansion into not
just a museum but an elaborate puzzle
box of sorts in and of itself it's a
home filled with secret rooms artifacts
and automated features including a
complex metal cage that wraps around the
entire structure with the flick of a few
switches eventually it's revealed that
the cage was designed by Voigt
specifically to trap the cenobites in
place allowing him to demand they remove
his liminal gift and free him from his
life of constant pain of course the
outside world doesn't know this or at
least they don't know it yet Riley may
tell her story to an interested party
perhaps the authorities will get wind of
the place and investigate regardless
it's likely that someone is going to
make their way out to Voight's Mansion
again and they're going to find a
chamber of Horrors that includes the
puzzle box still on the floor where
Riley left it what that means for the
future of the Box isn't clear but it's
likely someone somewhere knows exactly
what it is and what to do with it if
we've learned any anything from
Hellraiser films it's that these sort of
hidden places never stay hidden long
because the human pursuit of desires
never ceases almost everyone connected
to The Saga of the puzzle box and David
bruckner's Hellraiser dies one way or
another but Riley is not the only
Survivor of this particular story Cullen
the devoted partner to Riley's dead
brother and devoted friend to Riley
herself also manages to survive this is
thanks to Riley's last second decision
to leave Trevor to these cenobites
rather than let Colin die Colin's not a
major decision maker in the story at
least not in terms of the major moves
regarding the box and the cenobites but
he does have a crucial role to play now
like Riley he has to get on with his
life but what does that life look like
now that Colin has seen these Horrors
he's clearly not intrigued by them in
the same way other characters are but
they will remain imprinted on his brain
nevertheless it seems likely based on
the end of the film that he'll stay at
least somewhat close to Riley but as she
attempts to live a regular life with her
difficult history what does that mean
for Colin will he be able to find love
again does he have the horrible
distinction like White's former
associate of being cursed by the contact
he had with the box it's not clear but
the the road forward for a guy who's
been through this much won't be easy
though it delves into the secret of the
puzzle box more than any other single
previous Hellraiser installment the new
Hellraiser film still leaves numerous
questions about the box and its magical
properties unanswered we know what it
does and how it works but there are so
many other wrinkles that future films
could explore so many dark angles within
its various configurations the film
shows us that there are loopholes within
the rules of the box for instance there
is the Revelation that cenobites can be
sacrificed as victims as users of the
Box move through the various
configurations does that mean there are
other ways to summon and manipulate
cenobites Voigt found a way to restrain
them in his research which suggests
there are other stimuli and phenomena
they respond to and there's the more
straightforward question of how someone
gets such an artifact in the first place
are there dealers out there who
specifically traffic in such things
that's a question that seems ripe for a
sequel all its own
as with Hellbound Hellraiser 2 the new
Hellraiser film establishes the
existence of Leviathan a god figure the
cenobites serve but there are a few
tweaks to the mythology this time
Leviathan in this film retains the look
and feel that it had in Hellbound but
has the added power to grant wishes
these wishes exist because now the user
of the box is not automatically dragged
off to Hell by the cenobites instead
they're given one of a handful of
choices to make as the Box changes
configurations though the film doesn't
spend all that much time exploring the
depths and meaning of leviathan the very
existence of this being is both
fascinating and ripe for deeper
exploration and potential sequels what
else does Leviathan do is it just as
powerful as the biblical God are there
other ways to summon it how many
cenobites does it command and where do
they reside the ending of the film which
transforms Voit into a new cenobite
suggests a sequel might give us a more
thorough look at this story's version of
hell and that would be a welcome journey
in this newly reinvigorated franchise
unlike the puzzle box in previous films
the box in the new Hellraiser offers
more than one Pathway to new experiences
as Riley learns by going through
Voight's research the Box goes through
six different configurations and when
its wielders reach the end of the puzzle
they're able to choose one of six
different paths when you choose your
ultimate desire
life knowledge love sensation power
Resurrection
we see how three of these play out in
the film as Riley chooses lament and
Voit chooses first liminal and then
Leviathan but as Voit warns Riley before
he makes a second choice the consequence
of every decision is a trick by the
cenobites all they have to offer he
cautions is pain this of course begs the
question what do the other three
configurations do Riley considers
choosing Lazarus to bring her brother
back from the dead but stops when she
realizes it's likely a trap what about
the other two how far do they go in
transforming a human body into something
horrific where their gift of knowledge
transform you into a living brain
without a moment's piece does the gift
of love shroud you in such devotion that
you can never escape the one who loves
you nor they you these are excellent
little tidbits of the Mythos and would
make wonderful sequel fodder at the end
of the film when Riley could choose the
Lazarus configuration to potentially
bring her brother back she instead
chooses to live I know my brother's gone
this is the lament configuration it
represents a willingness to endure the
bitter and brief realm of human life
unaugmented it's a life that the
cinebites believe is full of regret and
mundane suffering it seems like the
right choice at the moment and it even
makes the cenobites return to their
realm but in the car with Colin at the
end of the film Riley doesn't look so
sure Colin asks her if her choice was
the right one and she doesn't have an
immediate answer it suggests that her
addictive personality wonders what might
happen if she goes back and picks up the
box again it would be so easy to take it
with her just in case just to see if she
might like to try a different
configuration one day it might even be
worth it to get her brother back even if
he's different than he was before
whether she changes her mind or not it's
clear Riley will be haunted by her
choice for a very long time and that
haunting might be worth exploring in
future films
[Music]